[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy last Halloween a Muslim named say
full o Sai paav drove a truck onto a
Manhattan bike path and murdered eight
people while screaming Allahu Akbar
in response the establishment media went
into a full-court press to convince
Americans that Allah - Akbar is not a
phrase that anyone needs to be concerned
about the worst article among many was
published in The New York Daily News
Zainab Chaudhary of the Hamas linked
Council on american-islamic relations
that is care argued that non-muslims
shouldn't believe the worst about Allahu
Akbar because Muslims don't just scream
it while murdering non-muslims but they
use it in a variety of contexts now
that's true but it doesn't change the
fact that Muslims scream Allah Akbar
while killing infidels because the
phrase means Allah is greater not God is
greatest as she falsely claims it is a
declaration of the superiority and the
supremacy of Islam Choudhary's
conclusion is chilling she wrote so the
next time you hear a lot luck bar
whether it's in a media report on an
airplane or in a shopping mall remember
that the phrase used by millions of
Muslims and Christians daily to praise
God regardless of their circumstances
can never be justified for use when
harming his creation now that's deadly
advice if you hear a lot bar yelled on
an airplane or in a shopping mall you
may well be in the middle of a jihad
terror attack if people on that airplane
are now conditioned by Chowdhury and the
establishment media they may not fight
back if people in that shopping mall
listen to Chowdhury they won't
immediately run because to do so would
be Islamophobic and so the casualties
will be maximized at CNN meanwhile Omar
Suleiman the same Imam who prevailed
upon Google to alter their search
results so as to bury any negative
information about Islam also argues that
Muslims say Allahu Akbar in a variety of
contexts many of them positive
he says a lone terrorist who shouts
Allahu Akbar while murdering innocent
people
in the streets of New York does not get
to own that term the way Allahu Akbar
often appears in the media seems to
serve a nefarious agenda to instill fear
of anyone who uh ters the phrase and to
raise concerns even about Islam itself
see if you notice that jihad mass
murderer is all over the world scream
allahu akbar as they murder people then
you have a nefarious agenda if you
remember that 9/11 hijacker Mohammed
Atta reminded himself to shout Allah
croc bar because this strikes fear in
the hearts of the non-believers you're a
hateful aslong elope Omar Suleiman even
cites the learner Imam John McCain to
make his case and he wants you to
believe that Allah Akbar is benign and
even beautiful and that there is no
cause whatsoever for concerns even about
Islam itself there's just one problem
so layman says the ones who get to own
the term live in a way that celebrates
the greatness of God by obeying his
commands and serving his creation not
those who flout those commands and
attack his creation unjustly but did say
fool disciple of really flout Allah's
commands did he really do something
unjust according to Islam the Quran
tells Muslims to wage war against the
people of the book which primarily
refers to Jews and Christians until they
submit to the hegemony of Islamic law
and accept second-class status the Quran
tells Muslims three times to kill them
wherever you find them chapter 2 verse
191 four eighty nine and nine five the
Quran tells Muslims to fight non-muslims
until religion is all for Allah and
Muhammad himself the prophet of islam
and the excellent example for muslims to
emulate says in the hadith i had been
ordered by allah to fight against the
people until they testify that no one
has the right to be worshipped but Allah
and that Muhammad is a laws apostle and
offer the prayers perfectly and give the
obligatory charity so that if they
perform that then they save their lives
and prop
from me except for Islamic laws and then
their reckoning accounts will be done by
Allah now was say full Saipan flouting
allows commands by thinking that kill
them wherever you find them actually
means kill them wherever you find them
did he murder people that Islam
considers innocent when Muhammad says
that only the lives of those who believe
in Allah are safe from him that the only
reason he won't kill them as if they
become Muslim not to be outdone the New
York Times actually tweeted that the
phrase Allahu Akbar had somehow become
intertwined with terrorism somehow how
could this possibly have happened could
it have had anything to do with the
thousands of Muslims who've screamed a
lot Akbar while in the process of
murdering infidels there's no mystery
here the association of Allahu Akbar
with jihad violence is not some new
practice in fact it couldn't possibly be
older Muhammad himself starts the
practice during his surprise attack on
the Jews of the Khaybar Oasis in Arabia
the biographer eben is Haq Muhammad's
earliest biographer says we reached
Khaybar early in the morning and the
inhabitants of Khaybar came out carrying
their spades and when they saw the
Prophet they said Muhammad by Allah
Muhammad and his army the Prophet said
allahu akbar Khaybar is destroyed for
whenever we approach a hostile nation to
fight then evil will be the morning for
those who have been warned unfortunately
for the media apologists the association
of allahu akbar with jihad violence goes
all the way back to the beginning of
islam right to its founding figure no
amount of media whitewash will change
that I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]